there's a few psychological tricks that
you'll include into some of your videos
what are some of those I'll mispronounce
words on purpose I'll share useful
websites like answerers socrates.com and
I'll say answer sratus and then people
run to the comments and they forcibly
correct me how dare you mispronounce the
legendary philosopher's name I'll also
sneak in folders right below the URL
that I share and it'll be something very
suspect like Mr Beast nud dot dot dot
that causes the person to say surely
he's not looking up Jimmy Donaldson
Nudes on Google or something like that
and they run to the comments they say
anyone else see this folder are we not
going to talk about this thing they
rewatch it to make sure that they
actually saw this and so it increases my
watch duration